one of the songs that
i remember when you first played me
grinding my whole life was at your house
it was probably six months before it
came out and i remember thinking to
myself this is the only song i've ever
heard that gave me
the same chills and vibes of grinding
from the clips like it just was so hard
and like
that's crazy the whole [ __ ] crew was
on it pops was on it
your dad was on it um
that song though the g-unit version
blew up you know see that's the thing
right
and i'll be thinking about this i'm like
so instead of just like
taking a [ __ ] style like 50 should have
just been like hey boy [ __ ] make an
album for us or come work with us
but it's like i think i feel like people
think too small you know what i'm saying
like [ __ ] like oh i see they having a
wave they got a heartbeat they got a
hard melody idea vocal idea let me just
take that
and try to wave up on [ __ ] versus
being a real one and being like i'm
gonna hit this [ __ ] and go make some
hard ass
that's what's gonna ask did you have any
sort of because
that song was so i know that was a very
important song for
your label and for your crew for my life
for your life
all of that video was crazy like did you
have any sort of uh
animosity towards the g unit version
i felt like people heard that b and
thought it was a g unit song
that weren't outside of i mean being
fans of what you were doing like
obviously you know what i'm saying like
at the end of the day bro you know like
i said man i feel like they was thinking
small by doing that you know what i'm
saying because it didn't really even
lead to nothing like he just said the
other day he want to forget about g unit
you know what i'm saying and like i put
my life on the line to
make that record put my whole family you
know saying not my whole family but all
my homies and put my pops on it like
that was a that was that was
that was real for us you know what i'm
saying like it wasn't just like oh it's
a heartbeat we just gonna rap on this
[ __ ]
you know i'm saying i feel like that's
what [ __ ] be thinking so it is what it
is